فوفو جديد
والعزيمه التي لا تهز وفي كل خطوه من
خطوات هذه الحرب المروعه كان الشعب
الامريكي داعما كبيرا لنظره الاوكراني
والحزب الديمقراطي والجمهوري
اتحداه والولايات المتحده وحلفائها في
العالم يعملون سويا للتاكد من ان الجيش
الاوكراني
اكبر يقدر من القوه للدفاع عن وطنه واسره
في مواجهه العدوان الغازي الروسي الامر
الذي اخذ فتره طويله من الزمن الولايات
المتحده
في هذا الصباح اجريتم محادثه مطور لامها
الرئيس الفرنسي مكرون ورئيس الوزراء
البريطاني سونيك
ومع رئيسه وزراء ايطاليا سوف نستمر
تنسيقنا المكثف حول اوكرانيا لانكم كما
تعلمون هذه المساله مر عليها فتره طويله
في مواجهه العدوان الروسي وسوف نكون
منخرطين ومتحدين بصوره كامله سوف نقوم
بالعمل على تعزيزي ووجود القوات الاخرانيه
في المناطق الموجوده فيها والتحليلي
وتحرير المناطق التي
احتلتها روسيا في ميدان المعركه على المدى
القصير هو لابد لهم ان يتحلوا بقدره
المناوره والتدريب يتم تعزيز القدراتهم من
اجل العدوان الروسي على المدى الطويل
وزير الخارجيه
ووزير او القوات العسكريه وزير الدفاع من
خلفي منخرطاني بصوره كبيره في هذه الجهود
وكذلك الجنرال اوستن
كان له دور حساس وجوهري لهذا فان الولايات
المتحده سوف تقوم بارسال وحد 31 دبابه من
طرازي ابرامز بالاضافه الى بطاريه خاصه
بها واليوم فانني ان الولايات المتحده سوف
تقوم بارسال وحده 30 دبابه ابرام 1 همم
والزير
وقدره الجيش الاوكرانيين للدفاع عن اراضيه
وتحقيق اهدافه الاستراتيجيه هذه الدبابات
هي الاكثر قوه في العالم وكذلك لديها طرق
معقده فصيانه سوف نعمل من اجل هذا الغرض
على تزويد اوكرانيا بقطع الغيار الضروريه
للحفاظ على هذه
الدبابات وصيانتها في ميدان المعركه من
اجل استمرار عمليه المقاومتهم من اجل نشر
هذه الدبابات في ميدان المعركه الامر سوف
يستغرقتا وهذا الوقت سوف نستخدمه ل يعني
جاهزيه القوات الاوكرانيه لاستخدام
الدبابات ابرام وكذلك ننسق مع حلفاءنا
وشركائنا المساهمه الامريكيه سوف تكون جزء
من
حزمه مساعده سوف تكون
جاهزه لتنشر في ميدان المعركه انني
المانيا
لمجموعه من الدبابات
لتشكيلتيبتين من الدبابات في اوكرانيا
الالماني على حسن قيادته وجهوده لدعم
اوكرانيا المانيا
كانت قد شمرت عن سعيديها هي الاخرى وكان
لديها صوت كبير في المجتمع الدولي من حيث
الدعم المقدم الاوكرانيه ان دعم قدراتي
اوكرانيا في مواجهه العدوان الروسي للدفاع
عن نفسها وسلامه اراضيها هي نوع من انواع
الالتزامات العالميه في الاسبوع الماضي
المانيا الوزير اوستن
كان على اتصال مع مجموعه الاتصال في
وهذه المجموعه مؤلفه من اكثر من 50 دوله
كل منها تقدموا مساهمات من تلقائي نفسها
من اجل ضمان الدفاع عن الاخرى وكل دوله
منها تقوم بمساعده اوكرانيا للدفاعاعي عن
اراضيها في مواجهه روسي كل عضو في هذا
التحالف الذي ساهم والمملكه المتحده
والولايات المتحده كان قد
المملكه المتحده سوف تساهم تشالنجر
من الولايات المتحده والمانيا سوف تقوم
بارسال
بطاريات
وهولندا سوف تقوم بدورها ايضا
بتقديم همم منصات اطلاق صواريخ هولندا
ودول الاخرى كلها سوف تقدمه اجهزه مختلفه
السماء
اوكرانيا من العهد من العدوان الروسيه
بولندا سوف تقوم بارسال مدرعات مصفحه هي
الاخرى وايطاليا سوف تقدم ايضا مجموعه من
من انظمه الدفاع والتوانيا سوف تقدم
مجموعه من الطائرات اعلنت في الاونه
الاخيره ايضا عن تقديم انظمه امنيه على
تذكره انه منذ فتره لم نكن لنحسب ان كل
هذا التطورات سوف تحسب سوف تحصل وخاصه في
سياق انضمامي فنلندا الى عضويه
سوف يتم ارسال اكثر من ثلاثه الاف مركبه
مصفحه بالاضافه الى اثنين مليون من انواع
الذخائر المختلفه وانظمه الدفاع عن البحر
كلها سوف تساعد على تعزيز قدره اوكرانيا
في مواجهه العدوان الروسي
ونعلان هذا اليوم
هو ليس الا استمرار العمل الداؤوب الذي
بداناه
من خلال قياده الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
للدفاع عن سياده اوه سياده اخرى وحمايه
اراضيها
فلا غير مقبول ان نستمر
هذا التهديد الروسي
فان انا سوف نعمل على تعزيز قدراتي
اوكرانيا
هو ان فريقنا لا يقوم بتقديم الالتزامه
لدوله واحده فحص باللي كافه الشركائنا
وحلفائنا
ان هدفنا هو الحفاظ على سلامه ووحده اراضي
اوكرانيا هذه هي المبادئ التي نعمل
بواحيها
اكثر من
143 الدوله
اوكرانيا الولايات المتحده سوف تقف كذفا
لكتف وجندا الى جنب مع كافه الحلفاء
لمساعده اوكرانيا فوت ان توقع من اوروبا
والولايات المتحده ان ان دعمنا لاوكرانيا
سوف يتلاشى
ولكنه كان
مخترعا في البدايه واستمر في ارتكاب نفس
الخطا الفاتح اننا متحدون الولايات
المتحده همم متحده مع بقيه دول العالم و
سوف نستمر في مواجههنا في وحدتها التصدي
للعدوان الروسي هذه الدبابات
سوف تكون هي من قبيل الالتزام الذي لا
يهزم من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
وكما الرئيس بالمناسبه اليوم عيد
بالمناسبه اليوم يصادف عيد ميلادي فاننا
سوف نقف معك مهما استغرق قال الامر من وقت
من الزمن فهذه المعركه التي سوف تقدم فيها
الولايات المتحده هو التي سوف نضمن من
خلالها فوز اخرىنيا ان المساله تتعلق
بالحريه حريه اوكرانيا وحريه الجميع
والدفاع عن بلادنا والقائهم محميه من كافه
المخاطر
لماذا اتخذتم هذا القرار الان
لماذا غيرتم رايكم بشان الخطه
كنت اود ان اتكت باننا جميعنا نقف معا في
هذا التواجد